[Music]
I am Saturn from the being questioned
and unfilled experience team and I'm
just introduced defined as what item oh
yeah
okay if you're such a
if you search how long to Randolph live
here you can say a new handsome and such
resolved between the wiki page and from
the wiki page your husband is out you
can get always get answer for the query
directory and if you not and if you want
to is promo and open they're there to
overlay show up in the search page you
can use maybe there is more like a
control F is such experience on the wiki
page and there's some enhancements such
as you could use conversational manners
for the query here try you
if you state with to represent the
ground dog if you just search before and
another extension here is that you could
get also for your what have you search
in highlights heart and you also use
some suggest questions is to is promo on
the wiki page I'm sorry how long do they
leave what's the groundhog and you will
get a result from the whole a directory
okay that's what we have